famously she was not for turning
survived on five to six hours sleep each
night found eating a burdensomeness esse
T didn't comprehend many jokes and left
a slew of European leaders trembling in
her considerable wake having just
celebrated it's been 40 years since
Margaret Thatcher came to power and as
US Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
referenced it in his speech this week it
starkly obvious how much we miss her
unique determination and single-minded
purpose it was to save this nation while
noting the stubbornness that was to be
part of her undoing think poll tax and
some policies were calamitous ly
ill-advised selling off school playing
fields this was a woman from a different
political age today when faced with a
crisis our politicians punt ponder what
they should say in her days it was
simply a question of what she would do a
poll last week showed the public see her
as the nation's greatest post-war leader
beating even Winston Churchill under her
we'd have brexit it within months of the
referendum so how shall we remember her
for me with a mixture of war and longing
[Music]
fascinating example of rewriting history
first of all she would not have been Pro
brexit with anti referenda and she
believed in renegotiating our position
in Europe not leaving it casting her
some kind of break near my corner is
incredibly ironic to me she would have
carried out the wishes and that's just
about where any praising her and I don't
even know where to start we are living
her legacy in so many negative ways
whether you take the complete calamity
of government and moment she is the
first leader to destroy collective
responsibility in cabinet government in
this country
she took the post-war consensus about
social justice and the welfare state and
begun dismantling it and we're still
seeing the consequences today in the
crisis in housing she begun that by
selling off council houses with no plan
as to how to replace the stock that
low-income families with badly needs
you know yes I agree that privatization
has it has brought wealth into London as
a financial center in the world I agree
I agree that that is part of her legacy
but the cost of that has been inequality
levels that are among the highest in
Europe and the idea of allowing
deindustrialization to completely
decimate northern communities with no
plan no plan as to how they could become
viable economic centres in the future
people are living with the legacy of
that today and you know when we look at
brexit I've never been dismissive about
the very legitimate grievances people in
bricks at heart nuns have feeling left
behind feeling that there's no plan for
them feeling that they are not sharing
in the growth in wealth in this country
but the reason for that is not sure what
the reason starts with Thatcher's policy
and it's still continuing
let's get Majid I'm not being cheeky but
you probably won't even ask or your
schoolboy either school trying to do
your homework
milk snatched okay okay so you were
possibly trying to do your homework
homework when the lights went out at
10:30 at night what so remember those
days I remember I was born in 77 gotta
say to balance out some of what was said
there are pros to Thatcher thank you
Premiership and the fact that she was a
three-time winner we've only had two
premier prime ministers in my lifetime
that I've done that Tony Blair and
Margaret Thatcher and so for me
transcending above some of the
legitimate criticism that a floor raises
is recognizing in what you said that we
are today suffering sorely from a lack
of leadership and I wish we had a leader
either like Tony Blair - Iraq and say
Thatcher - perhaps the housing crisis
and a few other things that we mentioned
that showed leadership in these
difficult times and showed us what
Statesman a woman ship really should
look like and that's where I I do agree
that that kind of quality perhaps today
is in short supply
Michelle credit to you you put your head
above the parapet you actually run for
election you tried to get into policy
and you get your fared well well and
good luck to you were you in anywhere
inspired by mrs. Thatcher well I think
market factor like anybody there's good
and there's bad but undeniably and I'd
be interested in your take on this
undeniably as a woman you've just done a
debate about how politics is sexist and
all the rest of it and how wives are
there as trophies and there is a lady 40
years ago who was the first Prime
Minister is there
part of you that feels inspired by her
in that in that way essentially because
I was born during Thatcher's time and it
definitely did something to my psyche
that the Prime Minister was a woman I'll
give her that I think but for me it also
reveals that the limits to what a woman
can represent I think it's good that we
had a female Prime Minister but she
didn't inspire me because her policies
were destructive for women and actually
just too quickly and I know you're in
the middle of speaking but if you look
at what men were paid and the gap gender
pay gap when she came into power which
was 66 P that men earned more than women
when she left power in 1990 it was 1
pound 62 and that's just one of many
that one happy economy she didn't leave
a legacy that necessarily empowered
other women and I think it is important
you know there was easy there was a
symbolism for me of having a women in
power but that doesn't mean that she
made things better for women I'm
guessing you're a sexist child as well
in a school board during that yeah and
which is why in 1997 was the one of the
best days of my life in that you know
all I'd ever know that one Tory this is
what Tony Blair was exactly and I have
to say I think one of the best days in
British politics was the day Margaret
Thatcher was booted out of office and
one of the one of the worst was when she
became leader I'll tell you why I agree
that yes as a woman it was wonderful to
have a strong woman in the position of
power who was very confident about her
power but in terms of what she did to
this country this is a woman who called
Nelson Mandela a terrorist oh yes I
won't say that this this is a woman who
did so much to actually divide our
country in the sense that she was not
somebody that was about unifying Britain
what she was about was making sure that
Britain continued to be a country that
was one that wasn't about being part of
a proper global community and also what
she did don't forget in terms of our
class system considering that she was a
working-class woman herself she did
nothing to dismantle our class system
she was somebody that was actually in
support of it so for me to be inspired
by Margaret Thatcher no way
it is but let's just spend of course but
probably every leader said something
dopey and I'm not supporting what she
said maybe maybe a bit none of you
realize the parlous state in which this
country was when she came to power never
not the sick man of Europe it was hardly
one of the sick men of the world we were
on a four-day week the lights went out
at night we've been I've been doing my
chemistry rubbish and you couldn't and
you couldn't bear please let me
inflation running at 25% the value
mortgages I mean it wasn't quite
Venezuela but it was headed that way I
do concede that so my mum it literally
would go to the shops and the prices
have gone up from week to make of a
price of beans and a loaf of bread that
was how it was the trade unions worked
quotes running the country not quite but
they certainly have more power than the
government did finally in her time in
her time she righted that I cannot begin
to describe how bad you don't put a ship
right unless you take some drastic
action please one of her the one of the
people that she most admired and that
that's the person that she based her
economic model on that's what
Thatcherism is based on is the economist
Friedrich von Hayek now do you not
accept that his policies have been
horrendous for the working class like if
we look yes in America if you look at
you it's the same economic model working
class people buying their own council
houses is emancipation and also I
remember just about some of the days you
refer to and I would like to concede
that they were terrible dark days in
this country it really worked out I
don't know they were actually physically
dark and they were also I mean we were
living in a cold and blighted country
and it was miserable and I remember
because as I said I was 77 I remember
vividly Thatcher changing some of that
and some of the conflicts around
changing some of that right I would say
that actually even when it comes to
homeownership though it has caused the
current housing crisis as you can see
agree it did though for an entire
generation of working-class people my
mouth included including my city
to become homeowners and therefore
become kings of all queens of their own
castles and that psychologically is
truly significant because it led to a
shift in expectations of what you can
what you can aspire to failing the
forward planning so it's one thing
giving you the opportunity to buy a home
that's great but if you're not thinking
you know it's a mixed bag yeah and also
some hand giving people the opportunity
to buy a home and then back to a force
point in terms of what she did to the
northern mining communities completely
decimating the ability for those people
to provide for himself in duration it's
positive more to get the cold out the
ground than the coal was worse
unemployed if you have to agree some
expire because drew I'm sure like I I
would you know I think Tony Blair is one
of the great leaders in this country
except the Iraq war and this is why I'm
saying it depends on who you ask because
if you go to Iraq they would probably
love Thatcher more than Tony Blair
because of the destruction that has been
you know so basically what I want to do
now post-war post-war because I
appreciate we might not be at work but
for Winston Churchill I'd like you all
to think about who your favorite
post-war prime minister might be and I'm
going for already know post-war was a
condition explain Majid you go first
right well this is Charles great and the
tea Oh grace named after him and the
reason I picked him is because he
abolished slavery and was a great
reformer and Rick and we need reform
today he was here an electoral system
well I chose Nick that's a baby
no I'm in check I didn't pay attention
to the brief and didn't realize it's
personal either so I chose Churchill
purely and simply because I really think
we need yeah
I win with Tony Blair yeah
well that say socialist and had fewer
than a quarter of his cabinet private
school educators yeah well phases down
we must face we must move on because
while many of us were getting married to
celebrate the extra long bank holiday
weekend one couple had a very good
reason for cracking open a bottle of
finest champagne the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex welcome to their first child a
boy on Monday morning celebrities and
world leaders rushed to congratulate
Harry and Megan on social media while in
their hometown of Windsor royal fans
were more than a little bit excited over
the new arrival here's how some of them
reacted to the happy news is this a sort
of particular special royal baby D thing
not really so you heard she's gone into
labor here anything I've just we've just
been waiting all day and we've just
heard now so how long do you think it's
going to take I have no idea I've never
been in labor I've only voted labour oh
it's fantastic news lilius wonderful me
this is what Brittany did today this is
what we've been needing I'm sick to
death of wrecks it was in Windsor I
think it's safe to say Royal baby mania
has reached fever pitch and for that
enthusiastic welcome to baby
Archie Patterson mountbatten-windsor
people Great Britain you are are
straight talkers of the week